hey everyone welcome to Simply lears
YouTube channel today we will be
learning about the top 10 highest being
artificial intelligence and machine
learning job profiles that said if these
are the type of videos you'd like to
watch then hit that like And subscribe
buttons and the bell icon to get
notified just for your quick info if you
want to upskill yourself master
artificially intelligence and machine
learning skills and land your dream job
or grow in your career then you must
explore simply learn scorad of various
Ai and ml programs simply learn offers
various certifications and postgraduate
programs in collaboration with some of
the world's leading universities like
won Purdue Caltech IIT conour and many
more through our courses you will gain
knowledge and work R expertise in skills
like generative AI prompt engineering
explainable AI machine learning
algorithms and over a dozen others
that's not all you also get the
opportunity to work on multiple projects
and learn from industry experts working
in the top Tire product companies and
academic from top universities after
completing these courses thousands of
Learners have transitioned into an AI or
ml role as a fresher or moved onto a
higher paying job profile if you are
passionate about making your career in
this field then make sure to check out
the link in the pinned comment and
description box below to find an AI and
ml program that fits your experience and
areas of Interest AI is changing the
world a lot it's like having helpful
friends on our devices like Siri and
Alexa who can understand us really well
also AI is like a secret helper in the
internet World suggesting things we
might like when we watch shows or shop
online but it's not just about making
life easy AI is doing big things too for
example in healthcare it's finding new
medicines faster and helping doctors
spot problems Early Air is also good for
the planet because it helps us save
energy and predict the weather more
accurately the future looks even better
with AI making our world more Innovative
and efficient at the same time it's like
a kind of a magic the more magical thing
about this field is the salary this
field offers to the professionals it's
mind-blowing and fascinating a Gartner
study reports that AI is an emerging
field that will create create 2.8
million jobs by 2025 so this video will
discuss the top five AI jobs in 2024
with highest salary this video will help
you in getting the answer to one of the
most sought after questions related to
artificial intelligence why you should
consider a career in this exponentially
growing field but before we begin if you
enjoy watching these videos and find
them interesting then subscribe to our
YouTube channel because we bring the
best videos for you daily also press the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply certifications provide the most
significant and well- defined part to
mastering any field on that note you can
also accelerate your career in Ai and
machine learning with our comprehensive
post-graduate program in Ai and machine
learning boost your career with this Ai
and machine learning course delivered in
collaboration with the per University
and IB learn in demand skills such as
machine learning deep learning NLP
computer vision reinforcement learning
generative AI prompt engineering chat
GPT and manual you will receive a
prestigious certificate and ask me
anything sessions by IBM with five
capstones and different domains using
real data sets you will gain practical
experience master classes by PD faculty
and IBM experts ensure top-notch
education simply learns job assist helps
you get notice by the leading companies
this program covers statistics python
supervised and unsupervised learning NLP
neural networks computer vision G caras
tensor flow and many more such skills
admission to this postgraduate program
in AI and machine learning requires 2
plus years of work experience a
bachelor's degree with an average of 50%
or higher marks basic understanding of
programming Concepts and Mathematics so
enroll now and unlock exciting Ai and
machine learning opportunities the link
is mentioned in the description box
below so without any further delay let's
start this video with what is artificial
intelligence artificial intelligence
refers to the development of computer
systems and software that can perform
tasks that typically require human
intelligence
these tasks include reasoning problem
solving learning from experience
understanding natural language
recognizing patterns and making
decisions AI aims to create machines or
softwares that can mimic human cognitive
functions enabling them to perform tasks
with worrying level of complexity AI is
surely one of the most sought-after
Industries for professionals looking for
a promising career and a lucrative
salary so let's talk about the top five
AI jobs with the highest salaries at
number five we have a computer vision
engineer a computer vision engineer is a
programmer skilled in creating software
using visual input sensors and
algorithms these systems can interpret
their environment as seen in
self-driving cars and facial recognition
computer vision Engineers uses languages
like C++ and python they work on tasks
like object detection image segmentation
facial and gesture recognition and scene
comprehension consequently the
compensation packages for computer
vision Engineers have become notably
attractive according to glaso the
average salary of a computer vision
engineer is
$155,000 in the United States and in
India it's rupees 8 lakh perom serving
as a significant incentive for
individuals venturing into this domain
at number four we have software
Engineers software Engineers handle
tasks from design to deployment but it's
rare to find experts in All Phases they
usually specializes in specific areas
this specialization applies to AI
software Engineers too they work on
various applications including machine
learning inference learning NLP and
intrusion detection covering different
aspects of AI development consequently
the compensation packages for software
Engineers have become notably attractive
according to glaso the average salary of
a software engineer is
$140,000 in the United States and in
India it's rupees 9 lakh perom serving
as a significant incentive for
individuals venturing into this domain
moving on to number three we have
machine learning Engineers a machine
learning engineer creates and deploys
training algorithms and models which is
the most demanding part of machine
learning most machine learning Engineers
hold Advanced degrees in computer
science mathematics or statistics due to
the need for advanced math skills many
also pursue specialized master's degrees
or certifications in machine learning
deep learning or neural networks
consequently the compensation packages
for ML Engineers as well is notably
attractive according to glasso the
average salary of a machine learning
engineer is
$150,000 in the United States and in
India it goes up to 11 lakh rupees perom
with additional cash benefits at number
two we have an AI research scientist AI
research scientists often computer
scientists focuses on innovating AI
algorithms and models their duties
include creating and evaluating new AI
models collaborating in research
publishing papers and presenting at
conferences while programming is a part
of their work it's just a portion unlike
the tech industry's openness to
self-taught programmers AI research
scientists need strong backgrounds in
computer science mathematics and
statistics consequently the compensation
packages for AI research scientists have
become notably attractive according to
glaso the average salary of an AI
research scientist is
$125,000 in the United States and rupes
21 lakhs perom in India with additional
cash benefits and finally at number one
we have an AI product manager an AI
product manager is much like other
program managers they oversee teams for
AI product development handling
schedules and Milestones to do this
effectively they need to understand AI
components like hardware and programming
languages which helps them support their
teams creating AI apps differs from web
applications in structure and
development processes consequently the
compensation is the highest for AI
product managers in 2024 according to
glaso the average salary of an AI
product manager is
$190,000 in the United States and in
India it goes around 26 lakh rupees
perom with additional cash compensations
so these are the top five job roles you
should consider entering in
2024 so let's go through the reasons why
AI individuals are are paid so much the
first reason is surging demand AI is in
high demand across Industries due to its
potential for Innovation and
competitiveness leading to higher
salaries for Professionals in this field
specialized expertise a specialist
possesses unique skills in areas like
machine learning and data analysis
justifying their higher pay business
impact ai's transformative potential for
businesses results in higher
compensation for experts who help
Implement AI Solutions Talent aity the
shortage of qualified AI professionals
creates intense competition among
employers driving up salaries and the
last reason is continuous learning and
Innovation AI experts are rewarded for
staying updated and Innovative in a
rapidly evolving field with the growing
demand for AI expertise skilled
professionals have opportunities to
boost their earnings by enhancing their
skills acquiring Advanced education and
gaining practical experience so let's
dive into four effective strategies to
elevate your AI engineer salary enabling
you to excel in a competitive job market
and negotiate more favorable
compensation the first strategy is
broaden your skill set continuously
expand your expertise in AI related
domains such as machine learning deep
learning natural language processing and
of course computer vision stay up to
date with the latest tools Frameworks
and algorithms by becoming an expert in
specific areas due to exceptional
Knowledge and Skills you can command
higher compensation pursue Advanced
education consider pursuing Advanced
degrees in AI or related fields such as
a master's or a post-graduate course
higher levels of Education often opens
doors to higher paying career
opportunities Advanced degrees not only
showcase your commitment to the field
but also provide you with an extensive
knowledge and research experience
significantly boosting your earning
potential gain practical experience
engage in real world AI projects to
accumulate practical experience and
build a robust portfolio explore options
such as internships contributions to
open-source projects and involvement in
AI research initiatives and the last
strategy is pursue industry recognized
certifications attain certifications
that are widely recognized in artificial
intelligence technology and framework
domain these certifications validate
your AI skills and competence
positioning you as a valuable asset for
companies adopting AI Solutions such
credentials gives you Competitive Edge
over other candidates and result in more
generous salary offers the job
opportunities in machine learning
are as wide- ranging and abundant as the
technology applications from sell
driving cars to online shopping speech
recognition and face recognition there's
virtually no significant area of Modern
Life that hasn't experienced a
transformation due to the work of
machine learning Engineers who build
them if you're aiming to work in the
field that offers impressive pay and
benefits along with excellent job
satisfaction machine learning is for you
moving forward we'll cover some top
machine machine learning jobs showing
upward machine learning salary Trends
the list covers machine learning
salaries by job role and geography on
that note if you're an aspiring AIML
engineer there's no better time to train
yourself in the exciting field of
machine learning if you're looking for a
course that covers everything from the
fundamentals to Advanced Techniques like
machine learning algorithm development
and UNS supervise learning look no
further than our celtech in partnership
with IBM this Ai and machine Lear
learning boot camp in collaboration with
keltech will help you advance your
career as an AI nml specialist this AI
ml boot camp includes live classes
delivered by industry experts Hands-On
Labs industry relevant projects and
master classes by keltech professors key
features of this amazing machine
learning course includes that is earn up
to 22 cus from Kelch ctme the next is
online convocation by keltech ctme
program director then we have simply
learned career services that help you
get no noticed by top hiring companies
and you will earn a boot camp
certificate from the celtech ctma and
the industry relevant Capstone projects
in three domains Kelch ctm is circle
membership 25 plus Hands-On projects
across industry verticals with
integrated Labs so why wait join now
seats are filling fast find the course
link mentioned in the description box
and pin command so without any further
Ado let's get started so number one on
the list is AI research scientist
a research scientist dedicates their
efforts to creating Innovative models
and algorithms within the realm of
machine
learning their work involves pioneering
research and exploring emerging Concepts
and Technologies this role Demands a
strong grasp of mathematics statistics
and computer science along with
Proficiency in programming languages
like python or R exceptional problem
solving abilities are also crucial AI
research scientists typically command an
average yearly salary of $91,000 in the
United States and in India an average
annual yearly salary is around 9 lakhs
per an moving forward let's see who
wants more than AI research scientist
and now number two on the list is NLP
engineer a natural language processing
engineer is a professional responsible
for crafting and constructing computer
systems that can process assess and
produce humanlike language NLP branches
out into numerous captivating domains
including semantic analysis sentiment
analysis face recognition machine
translation and speech recognition the
reach of NLP extends across a diverse
spectrum of applications notably
featuring virtual assistants chat boards
sentiment analysis customer service
interactions and natural language
translation the task of NLP Engineers
involves erecting these Innovative
applications and seamlessly embedding
them into existing Frameworks and now
the average salary for an NLP Eng
engineer is
$115,000 in the US and in India the
average annual salary for NLP Engineers
is 10 lakhs per an moving forward let's
see who owns more than NLP Eng genum the
next is data scientist a data scientist
harness statistical and machine learning
methodologies to derive valuable
insights from extensive data sets their
duties Encompass formulating
experimental designs crafting predictive
models and conveying their Revelations
to relevant parties vital Proficiency in
adeptness in programming languages like
python NR a firm grounding in statistics
and a Mastery of data visualization
given the substantial demand for their
skills data scientist command an average
yearly salary of
$128,000 in us and in India average
yearly salary is 14 LHS perom moving
forward let's see who wants more than AI
research scientist NLP engineer and data
scientist the next is machine learning
engineer a machine learning engineer
enger conceptualizes and constructs
models and Frameworks tailored for
machine learning purposes essential
proficiencies Encompass adeptness in
programming languages like python NR a
grasp of statistics and Mathematics and
hands-on experience in data manipulation
their dut is span handling substantial
data sets cooperating with vested
parties and Engineering Systems that are
both scalable and maintainable the
average annual income for machine
learning Engineers is $140,000 in the US
and in India it is 20 lakhs perom and
the last we have deep learning engineer
deep learning Engineers construct and
formulate intricate neural networks for
tasks like image recognition and natural
language processing profound familiarity
with deep learning Frameworks like
tensor flow and pytorch alongside
adeptness in programming languages such
as python is imperative Proficiency in
advanced mathematics and optimization
techniques is also indispensable their
duties Encompass the creation and
training of deep learning models
refining model efficiency and meticulous
parameter adjustments on average deep
learning Engineers earn an annual salary
of
$158,000 in the US and in India average
annual salary is 25 lakhs perom it's
important to note that salaries can vary
significantly based on location and
other factors for instance job
opportunities and compensation are
higher in Tech hubs like Silicone Valley
New York City and other major tech
centers worldwide to get the most
upto-date information on salaries and
job Trends in the machine learning field
check job boards industry reports and
salary surveys specific to your region
and Industry and with that we have
reached to the end of this session on
top 10 highest paying artificial
intelligence and machine learning jobs
should you need any assistance PP and
other resources used in the session
please let us know in the comment
section below and our team of experts
we'll be happy to help you as as soon as
possible until next time thank you and
keep learning stay tuned for more from
Simply learn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
Computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel Channel and click here to watch
similar videos to ner up and get
certified click
here